when I first got into red pill content I
didn't understand what the fuss was
after all I grew up in a nice area
I didn't have all these only fans chicks
around me so I didn't understand why the
men were complaining and in my head I
kept thinking not all women were like
that what I realized is to the average
guy there is no such thing as a good
woman let me show you why so we're gonna
make a chart this is the hotness scale
okay so this is a 10 this is a zero okay
now over here this is the body count
scale so this is how many people a woman
has slept you know the data says that
after about five to seven Partners a
woman is ruined dunzo gone okay so let's
just we'll do seven so this is seven and
Below women that are seven and Below
Partners uh this is so typically the men
they want to date ah let's just do let's
be generous let's just say fives and up
I know the guys are like no I won't do a
five but okay let's just be generous
today fives and up and let's just say
for a wife they want a woman that slept
with we're gonna be generous today okay
I think most men would prefer less than
five but today we're gonna do seven all
right so less than seven we have the Y
okay now let's just call a spade a spade
guys hot chicks get special privileges
they just do guys will say they won't
marry or datum they will so let's just
let's just call so the eights and up
that have slept and the not [__] five
and UPS okay now the issue we get into
is that we're in a modern world all
right so the men have no way of how they
can tell the difference between this
chick here who slept with a bunch of
people and this chick here right so
that's problem number one is because of
you know girls I mean you guys know the
sneaky cheating the sneaky doing stuff
and like rebranding all that whatever
guys don't really know for sure that
this girl is not this girl there's a
hard time to tell the difference
um and on top of that these girls
there's a ton of competition for so it's
pretty hard to compete and win one of
these girls because of the media because
now social media has it that the even an
average chick can get hit on by the top
one five ten percent of men in society
so the issue is if a guy does go for a
girl that hasn't slept around and is
attractive enough for him you know Drake
can come in and steal your girl on top
of that there's no way for them to know
for sure that she hasn't slept around so
the only solution is for guys to become
the best version of themselves right
because the only way you're gonna keep
one of these women with social media
which gives women a million options now
today is by being a guy that makes a lot
out of money being a guy that's in shape
being a guy that you know is assertive
masculine has game all the things that
you see all the other red pill channels
teach and it used to trigger me because
they would say oh just sleep with a
bunch of women right and initially I was
like well why would you want to do that
that's horrible but you have to remember
that a lot of guys teach this as a
response to women it's a response
because you know a lot of guys will say
oh it's so easy to tell the difference
between this chick and this chick but we
can all think of a guy that right you
guys could think of a guy right right my
producers are nodding that is dating a
born-again you know hoe or whatever and
he has no idea and guys aren't really
with that so that's why they preach that
I'm not saying do that or don't but it
kind of makes sense because when you
think about it the women are the ones
that aren't getting married young
because men will always want young hot
chicks and when the chicks are young and
hot they're not choosing monogamy
they're not choosing to get married so
you know what in that in this crazy
world what are guys supposed to do now
I'm not here to give prescriptions I'm
not telling the guys how to live their
life but I hope this explains why guys
like Myron say to sleep with 50 plus
chicks before settling down because yeah
you just kind of have to tell the
difference between these girls and these
girls so remember a lot of red pill or
you know pick up dating advice is
telling guys to adapt to the current
market now what is the current market
okay we're gonna draw the average chick
now remember there are women that will
be great wives and mothers there are
amazing women that like this is this I
have to a disclaimer isn't all women but
the numbers don't make us look good
ladies so remember the average chick
right this is Sally ninety percent of
women have been on birth control at one
point in their life one out of Threes
had an abortion one out of four has an
STD only five percent of women are
virgins on their wedding days okay the
average body count which women have
admitted to sleeping with seven guys in
college and a year now if you if you do
an aggregate of body counts you know
with older women younger women the
average body count is between five and
eight although you know guys really
don't don't believe that so again this
advice is for the average chick they're
not saying all women are like that but
let's just say a guy wants a virgin on
his wedding day it's only five percent
of of women so the question is why would
a guy Court a girl traditionally if
these are the women on the market can
you blame them now this isn't to hate on
women you know I'm a woman I like to
think you know not doing this craziness
but I the reason I'm laying this out for
you guys is a lot of more traditional
conservatives will judge the red pill
for the advice they give instead of
understanding this is the market and I I
hate to say it but the more freedom
women we have got sexually the more
we're on this debauchery this is the
body count to hotness scale
um uh let me know maybe I need to make
edits to this let me know in the
comments how we can improve this but
this is like a working Theory I have
like the video on your way out uh
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time